vous avez peut-être déjà vu ces petits
tubes en métal ce sont des cartouches de
protoxyde d'azote aussi appelées
gazilarant une substance dont l'usage a
été détournée par les adolescents pour
ses effets euphorisants problèmes sont
l'inhalation excessives et dangereuse
pour la santé alors à
Saint-Pierre-des-Corps le maire a choisi
de réagir en interdisant la vente de ces
cartouches au mineur ainsi que leur
utilisation dans l'espace public
reportage de Romain Delville
Saint-Pierre-des-Corps devient donc la
première commune du département a
interdire l'usage du protoxyde d'azote
du gaz hilarant dans l'espace public
ainsi que la vente aux mineurs on veut
pas que les jeunes se mettent en danger
la consommation de gassilarant c'est pas
forcément très dangereuse sauf si on en
consomme très très régulièrement
évidemment comme toutes les addictions
mais en soi il y a une perte complète
des repères et donc une mise en danger
de soi-même et des autres
et c'est ça qui nous importe sur quoi on
se fondre sur le danger potentiel c'est
uniquement sur le danger potentiel c'est
juste c'est un arrêté protecteur le
protoxyde d'azote est stocké dans des
cartouches comme celle-ci et il est
utilisé pour les siphons de Chantilly
mais détourner de son usage son
inhalation à un effet euphorisant qui
n'est pas sans risque problématique
c'est le d'abord à long terme c'est le
troubles de la vigilance avec tout ce
que ça entraîne donc une rupture
complète avec ce zombie avec son
environnement vous faites ça je sais pas
dans un endroit dangereux avec un risque
de chute vous pouvez éventuellement
inhaler si vous vomissez avec des
pathologies respiratoires et puis à
terme si jamais vous continuez le coma
enfin le coma le coma qui s'ensuit les
troubles d'investigences peuvent être
très importants des troubles d'autant
plus importants que le protoxyde d'azote
est souvent consommé avec de l'alcool